- The United States right now.
I don't believe I haven't
looked at those figures
in a while,
but I don't think that the
United States is the largest
polluter in the world.
I think that China and
India are above us.
Now, here you have four
and a half billion people
who are trying to get rich quick
and who are spewing a lot
of CO2 into the atmosphere
and who are also very
competitive with us
because they have
very low wages.
So, to tie ourselves to
the Paris Climate Accord
was the wrong way
to go about it.
And you know, what
else happened?
Was that the United
States has decreased
its emissions of CO2 per capita
at a faster pace than most
places in the world. Why?
Because we started getting
rid of our coal power plants
and we started introducing
more and more natural gas
into our electricity production
and natural gas burns,
or rather emits much
less CO2 than coal.
And so by simply, by innovating,
by basically changing
the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas,
we were able to decrease
our CO2 emissions
at a faster click than we
would have been obliged
to do under Paris.
(upbeat music)
- I am Dave Rubin. And
this is The Rubin Report.
Joining me today is the
Editor of HUMANPROGRESS.ORG
and the co-author
of the new book,
"10 Global Trends, Every
Smart Person Should Know"
and many others that you
will find interesting.
Marian Tupy welcome back
to The Rubin Report.
- Thank you very
much for having me.
- All right, Marian.
It is a week before
the election.
Everyone is going
completely insane.
And I thought, all right,
we're gonna talk
about some good news.
And that is exactly what
this book is all about.
And I absolutely loved it
because you've got graphs
and you've got charts
and you've got pictures
and it's a pleasant way
of getting some information,
but I thought the best way
to kick this off with you
would be why do you
think people are so
hesitant to believe that
good things are happening?
When I quote this book just
in private conversations
or when I have talks with people
that things aren't
getting so bad,
there's a real resistance to it.
Like they can't believe it.
Have you guys thought
about that at all?
- Yes, absolutely.
Look, human beings have
evolved to be pessimistic,
essentially our species is
about 300,000 years old.
And for most of that time,
life was extremely difficult.
The world was much less
hospitable to human beings.
And so we paid to be pessimistic
to expect bad things happen.
Any organism
that
understates the threats
may then be destroyed,
eaten, killed by predators.
But if you overstate the threat
nothing bad happens to you,
except you may lose a bit
of time or a bit of energy.
You know, if you're
going around a bush
and you hear some noise there
and you think, well,
everything is going to be fine,
but in fact, there is a tiger
or lion behind the bush.
Then that under reaction is
going to cost you your life.
And you're not going to
become an ancestor to anybody.
Whereas if you hear a
noise and you think,
well, there may be a lion
or a tiger behind that bush
and you run away.
Then of course, you're
going to pass those genes
onto your progeny
and over millennia,
hundreds of thousands
of years, those genes,
which are pessimistic are
probably going to survive
and they're going to
promote themselves.
Whereas the more
pessimistic ones presumably,
would be weeded out
of the gene pool.
So that's part of the reason,
and that's the hard
wiring of the human brain,
but you also have the soft
wiring of human brain.
Things like things
like, for example,
people fear losses more than
they look forward to gains.
This is called a
negativity bias,
which is called bad
is stronger than good.
We always remember the things,
money that we have lost,
but we forget the
money that we have won.
We remember the
criticism from the boss,
but we don't remember all
the good things they said
about our work.
And there are a lot of
these negativity biases,
which have developed over
millennia in our brains
and they make us into a
very pessimistic species.
- Yeah. It's also
interesting because you know,
people always complain,
Oh, well, if you
watch the local news,
it's so depressing because
it's just you know,
car accident, guy got shot.
You know, baby fell off
the roof blah-blah-blah
and yet people watch.
And if they just showed
good news in essence,
people just wouldn't watch.
- That's right. So we have
evolved to look for bad things
to be on the lookout
for bad things.
That's what grabs our attention.
There was a psychological
experiment a few years ago
where the psychologist
asked the cohort of,
well, the cohort of people,
whom they were testing,
the testing cohort.
Are you interested more in
the bad news or the good news?
And the cohorts said we are
interested in the good news.
Absolutely. For sure.
And then on a split screen,
this psychologist started
showing people bad news
and good news.
And immediately people's eyes
tended towards the bad news.
We are always on the
lookout for the bad things.
If it bleeds, it leads.
That's why the media
leads with bad news
because that's what
we are programmed to
consume with vigor.
- All right. So with that,
as the backdrop for
our conversation,
one week before the big
presidential election,
I want to go into the top
10 that you talk about here,
but the book has 78 trends
that are going well.
So, we're gonna plow
through the top 10,
and then I'm just gonna quiz
you on a couple of random ones
as well, but I'm going to
go through them right here.
So, the first trend
that you guys have
is the great enrichment.
And this is basically
about the economy.
So, can you lay this out?
Because a lot of people
think we're poor.
The divide is worse than ever,
and we seem to be getting poor,
but it's actually not true.
- Since the historical
record begun,
people lived on about
$2 per person per day,
2000 years ago at
the time of Christ
or Caesar Augustus, people in
America, in Europe, in Africa,
anywhere in the world,
lived on $2 a day or so.
That is why today when we
talk about absolute poverty
about living at a
subsistence level,
we talk about that $2 level
because that's how
people used to live
since the dawn of time really.
Now bring it back to
or bring it forward
all the way to 1800s
at the time of Thomas
Jefferson presidency,
global income per capita
per day is only $2.80.
So it's still very, very low.
But today 200 years later,
it is $44 per person
per day globally
in the United States is roughly
$160 per person per day.
And
if the current trends continue,
if we are able to repeat
the growth that we had
over the last hundred years
and project it to 2100,
then average global income will
be $144 per person per day.
So from $2, since
the dawn of time,
to $44 today,
to about 150 in 2100,
that's the extent of the
tremendous economic growth
that we have experienced
in the last 200 years.
And that we can still
experience in the future.
- So I think, one of the
things that confuses people,
at least when we hear this
through the mainstream media,
is there's this idea that
the rich keep getting richer
and that the poor
are getting poorer,
but the argument that you're
laying out in essence,
it's not that the rich
aren't getting richer.
Many rich people
are getting richer,
but that the entire pool
is actually being raised
at the same time.
So that the lowest person
is in far better shape now
than they were
say 200 years ago.
- That's correct.
The data which I have just
presented are data based
on global average, which
is to say a person living
maybe somewhere in
Indonesia or Malaysia,
right in the middle of the pack.
The data is not distorted by
you know looking at
just very rich people
and high income inequality
or what have you.
Globally, we are much better
off than we used to be,
of course, in well
advanced countries,
rich countries, people
are much richer,
but the world as a
whole is getting richer,
which is why poverty
has declined.
Absolute poverty has declined
for about 90% of
humanity in 1800
to less than 8% today.
I just want to
repeat that in 1800,
just 200 years ago,
90% of people lived on
$2 per person per day.
Today, roughly 8% of people
live on $2 per person per day.
So,
yes, the great
increase in riches
has resulted in a
substantial reduction
in absolute poverty.
We have seen a billion people
rise from absolute poverty
in China in the
last 40 or 50 years.
We are seeing India coming up.
We are seeing a number of
African countries growing
at 5% per year.
There's a lot of good news
that's happening in the world,
or at least there
was before COVID.
- And since this
election is a week away,
we should talk about the forces
that make all of that happen.
It has a little something to
do with free markets, right?
- That's correct.
The greatest decline in
absolute poverty in the world
is a core terminus
with the opening of the
global economy after 1980.
This is called the
period of globalization.
Now I realized that
a lot of people,
including a lot of people
in the United States
are ambivalent
about globalization,
but there is no doubt that
once these formerly poor
countries dropped socialism
and central planning
embraced free markets, embraced
multinational corporations,
and inward foreign investment.
Once that happened, these
countries started to grow
at a much faster pace,
which is why today
places like China are
middle income countries.
They are no longer dirt poor.
I mean, at the time of Mao,
these people literally ate dirt.
Today, they're sending
people to the moon,
well, at least to space.
So, like all this
- Yeah working on it
- The last 40 years have
been exceptionally good,
especially for poor countries.
- Yeah. All right. Let's
go to number two here,
which is really an
offshoot of this,
that in many ways, we're
at the end of poverty.
- Absolute poverty. Yes.
As you well know in
the United States,
we no longer have
absolute poverty.
Nobody lives on $2 per day.
Even people who don't
have a job can access food
and all sorts of facilities,
which are provided
by the taxpayer.
But globally,
absolute poverty had been,
or was before COVID at its
lowest it has ever been,
which is to say less than 8%.
And now of course as
countries become richer,
they start to redefine
poverty in a different way,
which is why in
the United States.
We don't talk about
absolute poverty
when we talk about poverty
it's relative poverty,
it's a certain percentage
of the mean national income
that we consider if people live
under that they are in poverty,
but we don't have absolute
poverty in the United States.
- So, you know,
from someone sitting
where I am in Los Angeles,
I'm seeing many more homeless
people than there were
a couple of years ago.
We know this is happening
in a lot of the big cities
in Portland, in Seattle,
certainly in San Francisco.
I think people see that, you
know, you see tent cities,
you see more homeless
people, et cetera, et cetera.
And the inclination is, "Oh,
well, I'm seeing something.
So it must be significantly
worse than it was."
But is it just that that's
happening in just some cities
or is it just that
your anecdotal evidence
doesn't really prove anything?
- Well, whether you look at
poverty as a relative measure,
relative poverty as a
percentage of national income,
or what do you look at
consumption poverty.
In other words, how much
do people actually spend
on a monthly basis,
a weekly basis?
Poverty is an all-time low.
I suspect that what's happening
in places like San Francisco
and Los Angeles is like new
policies have been implemented
by local governments, which
make it more attractive,
for people who may not
be necessarily interested
in jobs.
May not necessarily be
interested in normal lifestyles.
People who may, for
whatever reason prefer
the freedom essentially
of not being tied
to anything concrete and want
to live in these tent cities
and who may have been
living in those tent cities
throughout the United States.
But for whatever reason,
because the policies of local
governments have now changed,
these people are being pulled
like a magnet towards
certain jurisdictions.
And that's why you
see many more of them.
That would be, I think, one
reason you see that anecdotally?
- Yeah. And we do
know by the way
that they're putting
in policies in places
like San Francisco
and Los Angeles
that are attracting
more homeless people.
It's not something that
you're just making up,
at one point,
there was a policy.
I'm not sure if we still
have it in Los Angeles,
where if you build a
structure on public land,
they can't remove it.
You got an awful lot of
people paying mortgages
on land that they bought.
I don't know what
we're doing over here.
- I would simply add,
just to clarify one comment I
made in my last contribution.
And that is that when I say
that people don't necessarily
want to have a home and work
for a living, et cetera.
I'm not making a value judgment.
I'm saying that there
are a lot of people
who have very
different conceptions
about what a good life is.
And also in addition to that,
there are a lot of people
who may be mentally unstable,
who have all sorts
of mental problems
that prevents them
from keeping a job
and remaining in one
place at the same time.
- Right? So, and
naturally you're saying,
there are things
potentially that government
or private citizens can
do for those people,
but that overall this is
working and getting better
- Well, there are two
sides of that ledger.
On the one hand, you want
to do something for people
who are the very
bottom of society.
On the other hand,
that shouldn't mean
that you make life
unlivable for people
who live in these cities
and who actually pay taxes.
- Exactly.
All right. Trend number
three, this is interesting.
Are we running out of resources?
Everyone seems to think
we're running out of water.
We're running out of air. We're
running out of green space.
Are we actually running
out of resources?
- No, we are not
contrary to what people
have been worried about
since really the 1960s.
We are not running
out of resources.
In fact, resources
are becoming cheaper.
At HumanProgress, I have
an autonomous section
of HumanProgress called
the Simon project.
And in the Simon project,
we have actually calculated
that for every 1% increase
in human population,
the price of natural
resources declined by 1%.
What's happening here
is that more people
also produce more ideas,
and more ideas
can be put towards
not just the exploring
and exploiting greater
part of the earth.
More ideas can be used
in order to make us
more efficient in
the use of resources.
You know, 50, 60 years ago,
the can of Coke was
much, much heavier
than what it is today, because
we used so much more aluminum
in order to produce it.
But then smart people realized,
"Hey, why should we spend
so much money on aluminum?"
Because every time you
increase the price of an input,
you increase the
price of an output.
Why don't we save that money
by making the cans
of Coke thinner.
And so we are becoming
more efficient.
Also what we are doing,
we are replacing some
resources with others.
For example, we no
longer kill whales
in order to scoop out spermaceti
their brain mass, in
order to create candles.
Today,
we use fossil fuels
to power our lamps
and our cars and our
cell phones and whatever.
And maybe in the future 20,
40, or 50 years from now,
we will have fusion reactors,
which will basically
mean that electricity
will become essentially free,
will no longer have
to use fossil fuels
and therefore, any worry
that people might have about
us running out of oil or
natural gas will disappear.
- Yeah. One of the interesting
things about this trend
I thought was that your
answer basically said
sort of trust that human
ideas can solve problems.
And that in many
ways is so counter
to what we hear coming
out of the left, now.
You know, we hear about
the green new deal
and that this centralized
planning thing
can somehow magically
just sort of solve
all of these problems if we
just gave it enough power,
but in many ways, what
power and money, of course.
But in many ways
what you're saying
is you decentralize things.
You let people come
up with new ideas
and suddenly we will
have a thinner can
and less resources
will be taken,
and it'll actually be cheaper
and there'll be more
readily available.
- The answer to climate
change is not going to come
from central planning
and from restrictions
for two reasons, let's divide
the world into two halves.
In one half, you have
rich people like you and I
relatively rich, obviously,
living in democracies.
Now we are prepared
to pay a little more
for the protection
of the environment.
We are willing to
put up with taxes,
which are a little bit
higher, but not much higher.
In fact, all the opinion polls
and surveys suggest that
people are willing to put up
a little more toward
cleaning of the climate.
What they are not
prepared to do is to end
the first world lifestyles as
they know it, for the benefit
of environment or
climate change.
- Right isn't that in essence,
what was happening in France,
that they kept
raising taxes on gas
to do climate initiatives.
And that basically
started riots.
- And then you've got the
rise, the gorge homie.
And so there's this one half
rich people in
democracies will not vote
to end civilization, full stop.
Then you have the second
half of the world,
let's say very poor people
or relatively poor people
who live in countries,
which are not democracies,
places like that, places like
China and places like India,
the governments there
are not going to forego
the possibility of
rapid economic growth
and becoming rich,
just because people in
rich countries demand that.
We should demand it of
them because it is immoral.
And those governments
are not going to do it
because they're not suicidal.
Even China, which is a
totalitarian, an awful regime,
and which keeps saying we
are going to go carbon free
by this date and other date,
they're building a record number
of coal powered
power plants, as we speak.
In other words,
they understand that
there is nothing surer to
destroy the Communist Party's
hold on power than denying the
Chinese people a better life.
- Yeah.
Is that sort of an
offshoot of the rationale
that got us out of
the Paris Accord.
That in essence, these
countries were gonna keep doing
these things because
they had to do them
as they go through their
industrial revolution.
It's talking say
about China and India,
while we were going to put
regulations on ourselves,
and pay for the brunt of it.
And there was no enforcement
mechanism and everything else.
- I think that was
a part of it is that
the United States right, now.
I don't believe I haven't
looked at those figures
in a while,
but I don't that
the United States
is the largest
polluter in the world.
I think that China and
India are above us.
Now, here you have four
and a half billion people
who are trying to get rich quick
and who are spewing a lot
of CO2 into the atmosphere
and who are also very
competitive with us
because they have
very low wages.
So, to tie ourselves to
the Paris Climate Accord
was the wrong way
to go about it.
And you know what else happened
also the United States has
decreased its emissions of CO2
per capita at a faster pace
than most places in the world.
Why?
Because
we started getting rid
of our coal power plants
and we started introducing
more and more natural gas
into our electricity production.
And natural gas burns or
rather emits much less CO2
than coal, and so by
simply by innovating,
by basically changing
the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas,
we were able to decrease
our CO2 emissions
at a faster click than we
would have been obliged
to do under Paris.
- All right. So let's move
on to trend number four.
I thought this was interesting
'cause I see a lot of talk
of this kind of thing online
related to peak population,
and that we're putting too
many people on this earth.
Is it true?
- It is not true.
Right now, there are
7.8 billion of us.
The global population will
peak in about 2060, 2070
at roughly 9 and nine
and a a half billion.
And then it will
start declining.
There are a number of
studies done on this.
The latest one came from Lancet,
which is a very highly
regarded British medical paper.
And what they have
concluded is that by 2100,
there will be anywhere between
6.8 and 8.8 billion people
in the world.
So roughly 1 billion,
less than we have today,
or 1 billion more.
I'm very ambivalent
about this trend,
because I think that because
humans are the only entities
in the world capable of
actually producing ideas.
If you are going to come
up with a cure for cancer,
if you're going to come up for
a solution to climate change
and fusion reactor, you need
the human brain to do that.
Artificial intelligence
is simply not there yet.
So, fewer human beings we have,
the harder it will be to
produce enough geniuses
to come up with ideas,
to solve our problems.
Nonetheless, the reality is
that the total fertility rate,
which is to say the number of
babies that a woman can expect
to have in her life,
is now roughly around 2.4
replacement level
is 2.1.
Replacement level
basically means that
if you have fewer
babies than that,
the global population
starts declining.
In Europe, in places
like Czech Republic,
where my ancestors
are from or Slovakia,
the total fertility rate is
1.3, 1.4, rather than 2.1,
which is needed just to
keep the population steady.
And the only place
really, which is above
2.1, 2.4
is Africa.
Population of Africa,
is still going to
increase for a while,
but globally we have
fewer and fewer babies
being born per
woman. Why is that?
Is because women are
getting education
and they are getting work.
What happens when
a woman gets work,
is that the opportunity
costs of staying at home
and taking care of
children increases.
She can do with her
life other things,
she can earn a lot of
money in the marketplace.
And so she has fewer
and fewer babies.
This relationship, we
are seeing it no matter
which continent
you're looking at it,
we see it everywhere.
And we expect that as
Africa becomes richer,
African women will start
having fewer and fewer babies
below the replacement level.
- Yeah. Some of this stuff
feels like it must be hard
to track because
if you were to say,
Okay, let's look 100
years in the future
with the trends of how people
are reproducing right now.
Well, all sorts of
other trends change
and food changes and
migration patterns change
and everything else.
So that, that explains
why it could be 1 billion
over or under, right?
- Correct. It was also
based on assumptions
about economic growth
and access to education.
We expect that the economy
will continue to grow.
I mean, if the
economy stops growing
or if there is a de-growth in
certain parts of the world,
then the relationship
between increased wealth
and fewer babies obviously ends.
- Yeah. When you guys are
tracking stuff like this,
you've referenced,
COVID a couple of times,
how do you plan for in the
models things like COVID.
I mean, if we just took
this back eight months ago,
nobody expected this sort
of a worldwide shutdown
of an economy
and the health stuff.
- Right? I mean we don't
model anything in the book,
I do modeling on
natural resources.
But the book itself is
a compilation of data
from third-party sources,
from inter-governmental
organizations,
from the United Nations,
from the US Government
from Eurostat.
We don't come up with any data.
- By you guys I
meant the modelers.
Not you guys specifically
writing the book.
- Well,
almost nobody saw this coming.
I mean there were a few
people who were saying,
this was a serious possibility,
such as Bill Gates
and kudos to him
for predicting five years ago,
that this was the
most serious problem
that humanity was going to face
in the short to medium term.
But most people were
worried about climate change
and things which
could become serious.
If we don't do anything,
if we sit on our hands,
it could become serious
in 50, 60, 70 years.
But we weren't looking
closer to home.
We weren't looking
at our own bodies
and inside of our own bodies.
We weren't looking at
the natural evolution
that's going on
with viruses and bacteria,
which are happening
at a much faster click
in the body of every human
being and every animal.
And I think that it's
a rude awakening.
It tells us something
about complacency.
It tells us something about
appreciating modern life
appreciating also human contact,
being deprived of
all of those things
I would hope would make us,
more grateful
for the world that
we had before COVID.
- Speaking of grateful,
trend number five,
the end of famine.
I mean, I remember
growing up in the '80s
and what was
happening in Ethiopia
and that this was something
that you talked about,
that there were places in
the world where people simply
were starving to death.
This is being eradicated.
- That's correct. I mean,
we are roughly the same age.
And in the 1980s, I
remember very distinctly
those horrific pictures
from the Horn of Africa,
Ethiopia, Eritrea,
children with swollen bellies
from famine their
eyes covered by flies
and that sort of thing.
And we really thought
that this was going
to be the future of humanity.
A couple of things
have happened.
One the world has become
a much more peaceful,
which is to say that
the kinds of conflicts
that we saw in Africa,
partly as a result of
the cold war in the 1980s
have pretty much disappeared.
I mean, we still have civil
wars, but countries no longer
really go into wars
against one another.
The other thing that's
happened was that socialism
and communism ended.
And these countries have
opted for free markets
and greater production
or a better production, greater
production in agriculture.
Once you don't have communism,
once you're going
to have socialism,
once farmers have a
stake in their own farms
and in their own productivity,
they tend to produce more food.
And so globally, we have
seen tremendous gains
in food productivity
per acre of earth.
People no matter whether it's
they're in the United States
or in India, or China or Africa
are producing more food
as a result of which
in Sub-Saharan Africa today,
people have on average
access to as many calories
as the Portuguese did
in the early 1960s.
I just want to repeat that
today in Sub-Saharan Africa,
we no longer looking at famines.
In fact, obesity is
becoming a problem,
especially in urban areas.
Instead, what we have
is food productivity
and access to calories
equivalent to where Portugal
was in the early 1960s.
Nobody saw this coming. It's
a marvelous development.
Today,
the global production
of calories
is about 3000 per
person per day.
And United States, Department
of Agriculture recommends
that people should be eating
about 2000 calories
per person per day.
So, there's plenty
of food to go around.
It doesn't mean that
everybody is well-nourished
because of course there are
always people in remote areas
or people be set by civil wars
who don't have access to food.
But we are already producing
one third more calories,
than we hypothetically
need in the world today.
- Right? I mean,
that's more calories
than I'm trying to
eat on an average day.
- Which also means that
if the world's population
by some miracle
increased from 8 billion
to 11 or 12 billion,
which won't happen.
But today we are
producing enough calories
to feed the world
in 2100 and beyond.
- Yeah, it's incredible.
So, trend number six.
I thought this was interesting
because I feel like
no matter what
you're about to say,
people just are not
going to believe this.
A certain set of people
and you know what,
we'll actually throw up
the image on this one,
when we talk about
it for trend six.
This is there's more
land for nature.
I feel like people just
simply won't believe this,
but take it away.
- Well, what happens
as an increase
of agricultural productivity
first,
and
urbanization second
is that there's more
land left for nature.
So
today, roughly 55% of
humanity lives in the cities
by 2100 it will 80%.
Sorry, by 2050, 80% of humanity
will be living in cities.
What that means is that 80%
of people don't live on land.
And what that means
is that all that land
can now be returned to nature.
Nature will re-concur it.
It doesn't need to be told.
Animals will spread,
forests will grow.
And of course, so that's
the result of urbanization.
Also as a result of
agricultural productivity,
we can produce
more food per acre.
And that means that we
can feed more people
on an average shrinking amount
of land as a result of which
the land sparing as it is called
is growing.
I think the statistic
that we have in the book
is that in the last
20 years or so,
we have saved the land the
size of Alaska for nature
or something like that.
- Yeah. It's just incredible.
I mean this is one of the ones
where something like COVID
does seem like it changes
the calculation a bit,
because right now at least,
we're seeing people
move out of the cities
but you think the overall
trends will be that
eventually they will move back.
- Well, see what happens.
I mean, after 911 people
were predicting the death
of New York and New
York had of course,
incredible two
decades ahead of it.
You know, some people like
to live in like the idea
of living off land and on land
and the moment they start
farming and tending to horses
and cows and et cetera,
suddenly they start missing
the math or, you know,
the restaurants in the city
and the company
of their friends.
And so,
I don't think that we are going
to see the death of a city.
And
moving forward I think that
urbanization will continue,
especially in
developing countries
where the need for nature
sparing is the greatest.
- Yeah. Well, that's the
perfect segue to trend seven,
which is planet city.
Talk to me about that.
- Well, planet city is good
for the environmental reasons
that I outlined.
One other reason that
I would want to...
one other environmental reason,
I would want to bring
up why cities are good
is that on average,
a city dweller
uses less energy and emits
less CO2 than a farmer.
And just give it one example.
I mean a farmer needs to
drive much greater distances
in order to tend to his
stock or to his fields.
Whereas your typical urbanite
may have to walk,
a few meters to his
or few feet to his bedroom.
- Well, in essence now
in his bedroom, right?
- Or alternatively,
your typical urbanite
will use public transport,
which is not obviously available
to a typical farmer.
So, that's another reason
why urbanization is good.
However, urbanization is
vital for another reason.
And that is that urban
centers are the drivers
of social and economic progress.
Since the dawn of time, really,
since the dawn of the city,
it was in the cities
that economic progress
took place. Why?
Because when you have a
large number of people
who live together
in close proximity,
who trade together,
who communicate
together and so forth,
you also have a greater
intermingling of ideas.
And once you have that
exchange of ideas,
those network effects
of a lot of people
communicating together,
you are going to also
have more ideas that lead
to economic growth,
technological,
medical and scientific
changes and so forth.
And finally cities are good
because they tend
to be more liberal,
not in American sense,
although to some extent,
but certainly the
classical liberal sense.
When you look at Amsterdam
in 18 and 17th centuries
being very tolerant of Jews,
or when you look at
Florence in 15, 16 centuries
being very tolerant or
comparatively tolerant
of sexual minorities,
such as homosexuality,
or whether you look at
New York in the 1950s
being much more progressive
when it comes to racial issues
and the treatment
of black Americans,
cities are
socially
much more tolerant than urban
sorry, than rural areas.
- Yeah, it's fascinating.
So, we need cities, which sort
of brings us to trend eight.
We're told and now we've got
an election just about a week.
We're told that fascism is
spreading all over the world,
but actually democracy
is on the march.
There's good things
happen, what's going on?
- Everything depends
on your timeframe.
Certainly democracy has
been on the back foot
in the '70s and the '80s.
But with the fall
of communism in 1989
and the destruction
of the Soviet Union,
the self implosion of
the Soviet Union in 1991,
democracy has spread
around the world.
And it is true that the
process of democratization
has slowed, but it is not true
That democracy is in retreat.
We are not seeing some sort
of a wholesale acceptance
of dictatorship
and totalitarianism
that's spreading like wildfire.
Yes, it is true that Turkey
is no longer democratic,
but it's also true that
Sudan of all places
overthrew its dictator,
and it's going to have elections
in I believe next year.
It is true that Russia
has abandoned its experiment
with democracy under
the regime of Putin.
But it's also true that Nigeria,
which is going to be probably
the third most populous
country by 2050,
it's going to be twice the
size of the United States.
Well by 2100.
Nigeria has overthrown
or rather has
democratically transitioned
from one form of
government to another.
That's Nigeria transitioning
peacefully from opposition to
or from government to the
opposition and back again.
So
there are a lot of places where
democracy is improving
or alternatively,
where fascistic or
autocratic regimes
are under a tremendous pressure.
And we are not seeing
a wholesale abandonment
of democracy.
No.
- Yeah. It's interesting
that the backdrop
of that is you're
saying that Russia
has sort of gone the other way.
Turkey has sort of gone the
other way, where 10 years ago,
they were heading in
the right direction,
but despite all that,
democracy flourishes elsewhere
and most likely,
well, hopefully Turkey will
have a comeback you know
and Russia will have a comeback
and this will continue
spreading all over the place.
- I bet that that will happen.
It's very difficult to
envisage a sort of a peaceful,
normal power transition from
Putin to somebody like him.
There will be a lot of tensions
there, but more importantly,
I don't think that
authoritarians
countries are presenting
an attractive option for
people who are dissatisfied
with democracy.
Look, yes, we have problems.
I mean, look at our candidates.
There are problems.
There are problems
in other countries
with democratic inefficiency
places like Britain
and elsewhere,
However, what does
Russia have to offer?
It has a cartoonish autocrat
who is presiding over
what is essentially a
glorified petrol station
and every young person
who can gets out of Russia
because it offers
no future for them.
It's some sort of a
combination of fascism
and religious conservatism
that is not really appealing
to a lot of people in the world,
not to mention that
it's a Russian Orthodox
authoritarianship, not really
something that sells well
in say Nigeria or in Peru.
Then you have China.
Now, China for a long time
seemed like a very interesting
alternative for a lot of
people who are not really keen
on democracy.
What do we know about
China now on the Xi?
We know that they're
putting millions of people
in concentration camps.
That they are implementing
a genocide against an ethnically
distinct group of people.
We know that because of
their ineptitude and secrecy,
they have made the
COVID pandemic worse
than it would have had to be.
So, I think that that
is a lot of shine
that has come off
China in recent years.
- Interesting trend nine.
I think people will be able
to believe this is real,
the long peace that
where actually the wars
of the last hundred years
are winding down, in reality.
- Yes.
Right now it's actually quite
strange to talk about it now,
because we do actually
right now have a conflict
between two countries and
that's Azerbaijan and Armenia,
but what's so interesting
about that conflict
is that the two countries didn't
declare war on each other.
And in fact, I think
that the last time
that a country
declared war on another
was the Korean war between,
between the United
States and North Korea.
And in fact,
international conflict,
which is to say two
countries that declare war
on each other,
and then send armies
across borders
to slaughter each
other's citizens
that has pretty much
disappeared from the world.
What we do have,
we've had an uptick
in recent years in civil wars.
So, pretty much all the
conflicts that are happening
in the world today
are civil wars.
They're no longer
international conflicts,
they're are civil wars.
And there has definitely
been an uptick in civil wars,
but nowhere close to
the number of civil wars
that were taking place
in 1970s and the '80s.
So even though, yes,
we are not at
a historically low
level of conflict,
we are certainly at a much
lower level of conflict
than we were in the
'70s and the '80s.
And that's why you need
the long-term data,
because just when you think
that things are being bad
and that we've lived
through some, I don't know,
five years of negative news,
look what was happening in
the world in the 70's and 80's
compare it and you'll be happy.
- Yeah. And that brings
us to trend number 10,
which is that we are
living in a safer world
than we have in a
very, very long time.
- Yes. Well, this particular
trend goes contrary to
the wisdom being espoused by
people like Thornburg and AALC
and
that the apocalyptic sect
within the
environmentalist movement.
There are a lot of
smart environmentalist
who are making very
reasonable points,
but the apocalypticists within
the environmentalist movement
are saying that we are going
to lose millions of people
to climate change.
The last trend shows
the number of people
who die as a result
of natural disasters.
These are not things that
humanity has any control over.
We are talking about
earthquakes and tsunamis
and what we have seen,
and I kid you not, and I urge
people to go to trend 10,
is that the number of fatalities
due to environmental disasters
or other environmental
disasters has declined by 99%
over the last a hundred years.
Why would that be?
One reason is that
as we grow richer,
we are able to build
more sturdy dwellings.
So, as architecture becomes
more resistant to earthquakes,
flooding and so forth,
obviously fewer people die.
And another thing that's
improved is science.
We have satellites which are
able to track the formation
of a storm in the Caribbean.
We can project its
trajectory along the coast
of the United States.
We can predict its
landfall within, you know,
few dozens of miles.
And all of that means
is that we gain time
to prepare for storms and
hurricanes and tsunamis.
Well, I'll get to
tsunamis in a second.
And therefore fewer people die,
even when it comes to
tsunamis, what do we have now?
We are able to monitor the
ocean floor for earthquakes,
which then
send information via sensors
to the mainland of Japan
saying, for example,
saying that 200 kilometers
to the East of
I don't know, Tokyo.
- Let's go with Tokyo.
- Yeah. And you can
expect a tsunami in
36 minutes.
And that means that a
lot of people can move
to higher ground or can
prepare or whatever.
- Yeah. All right.
So those were the top 10 that
you guys focus on in the book.
Now I'm going to really
challenge you as an author
because I'm going to
randomly flip to three more.
We will finish with
three more of the 78.
And let's see if you know
what you're really talking
about here. So here we go.
All right.
Trend 52, rising
natural gas reserves.
We've actually got extra gas.
I know we've got a lot
of wind bags out there,
but we've got extra gas.
- That's right. So,
before I go there,
actually let me say that
I don't actually know
if a Tokyo is on the Seacoast
or not, but nevermind.
I'm gonna get a lot
of hate mail for that.
But when it comes to gas, what
happened was extra ordinary.
And that is that in the
last 10 to 15 years,
last 10 years, shale fracking
has become much more efficient
than people ever assumed.
And so a lot of natural gas
that was trapped in rocks
and you couldn't get to it.
We can now get to because
of superior technology
that people decades
ago didn't have.
And so the known
reserves of natural gas
are now at a record level.
So, in spite of the fact
that we've been using
natural gas for decades,
we now know have more
reserves than ever before.
That has the positive
effect, of course,
of driving down the
price of natural gas.
When you have natural
gas that is very cheap,
you can then use it instead of
coal generating electricity.
When you use it, instead of
coal generating electricity,
you are emitting fewer CO2
emissions into the atmosphere.
So that is shale, that
is shale fracking.
And we are very lucky
that in the United States,
we are the center for some
of the most innovative minds,
because this is very much
an American success story.
- There you go. All right,
I'm randomly selected here.
Here we go.
Oh, 41. This will be
an interesting one.
Nuclear arsenals are
actually going down.
- Yes. So at the height of
the cold war in the mid 1980s,
the United States and the
Soviet Union had something,
on the order of
20,000
nuclear warheads each
aimed at one another.
If those exploded
at the same time,
it would be over
for civilization.
The planet would have been
uninhabitable, the end.
What has happened since then
is that I believe we are down
to about 3000 nuclear warheads
per Soviet unit, per Russia
and per United States.
So, we have
decreased the amount,
the number of
warheads dramatically.
Now, unfortunately
in recent years,
there has been some backsliding
on these international treaties,
which are regulating
how many nuclear weapons
a country can possess.
And it's possible
that in the future,
the number of nuclear weapons
possessed by China, India,
United States, Russia, and so
forth, will start climbing.
And we should be on top of
this. It is a serious problem.
It is a serious problem
because the knowledge
that we have in terms of
producing nuclear weapons,
that cannot be unlearned.
You cannot put it
on a shelf somewhere
and hope that people
will forget about it.
I think that what we
should be aiming for
is having the scientific
community tell us
what would be the minimal
number of warheads
that could go off on earth
whilst at the same time,
preserving civilization, some
semblance of civilization,
preserving humanity, and
then distribute that number
of warheads or access to
those numbers of warheads
amongst nuclear powers.
So, I think we should be going
in the opposite direction.
We should try to get
nukes as low as possible,
and
then have some sort of a
proportional distribution
amongst great powers.
- That would be a hell
of a meeting trying
to get proportional
distribution.
- We've done that before.
We've done that
before in the 1920s,
the United States presided
over the naval disarmament
between the United States,
France, Britain and Japan,
where there was a key according
to which Naval warships
juggernauts were
sorry, not juggernauts,
dreadnoughts were distributed
amongst different, great powers.
And I think it was
something like 10, 10,
seven, seven, four, four,
depending on the power of
the relative power
of that great power.
But my point is, we
had done this before
with what was then the
equivalent of a nuclear weapon,
which was the Dreadnought ship.
- Yeah. Interesting.
All right. Which
way should I go?
You want me to go to
a lower number than 41
or a higher number than 41.
This is really going
to test you now.
- You'll be more confident
with lower numbers.
- All right, here we
go random, random.
Here we are tuberculosis.
Let's skip that.
Here's a good one to end on.
- Talk about COVID
later, but nevermind go.
- Here we go, number 24
the last one from the book,
and then we'll end on that.
Life expectancy is
actually rising,
which is sort of consistent
with a lot of the other stuff
that we're talking about here.
- Yeah.
So
obviously we can look at,
we can look at the
skeletons of people
who lived 10,000 years ago,
and then create some
sort of a picture
as to what was the
life expectancy
back at the dawn of time.
And it seems likely that
life expectancy was between
25 and 30 years.
Now that doesn't mean that
everybody lived to about 30
and then they suddenly died.
There were some people who
lived into their sixties
and perhaps into
their seventies.
The reason why people's
life expectancy was 25 to 30
was because so many
babies died at childbirth
along with their mothers.
But child mortality was huge
anywhere between one third
and one half of children born.
Now, once you made it
past the age of five,
you had a decent
chance of living
into comparatively
old age, say sixties,
but obviously as a
result of medical
and technological breakthroughs,
as a result of wealth,
as a result of this
great enrichment,
which humanity has experienced
in the last 200 years,
and as a result of
access to better food,
better nutrition and
better sanitation.
Life expectancy rose to about
50 by 1900 in rich countries.
Today
it is 72 globally,
and 79 or 80 in rich countries.
So, let me just repeat that,
life expectancy in the
richest places in the world,
such as Britain and the
United States in 1900 was 50.
Today, it is 80 and globally
it is about 70 to 73.
So, we are already
living much longer lives.
And, you know,
depending on which way
the biomedical industry goes
and tremendous improvements
in healthcare,
genetic coding,
we could expect to
extend our lives
our life expectancies in
mine and your lifetime
beyond a hundred
years, very easily.
- We're gonna have to
stock up on multivitamins.
I think that's the
answer right there.
All right, so to end this,
although it is not in the book,
can you give us some
good news COVID related
or just what you're seeing
the research saying relative
to us just getting
past the pandemic,
past the lockdowns.
What does a decent
future look like?
- So, I actually think that
trend 34 is devoted to it,
but let me just take
you through what it says
- Trend 34, you're good.
- I think so. It's been one
that I've been using a lot
because obviously a lot of
people are asking about COVID.
- Yeah, right? So
34 is accelerating
vaccine discoveries.
- Correct.
So
let's take what was probably
the biggest killer of
humanity in history
and that's Smallpox.
I mean, in 20th century alone,
it killed between 300
and 500 million people.
That's an extraordinary thing.
And obviously we don't know
how many people it killed
prior to that.
What we do know that
in 18th century,
80 to 90% of people in Europe
could expect to develop,
to catch and develop
symptoms of Smallpox.
So Smallpox was a terrible
killer of humanity.
And we can trace Smallpox
going all the way back
to ancient Egypt
and ancient India,
about three and a half
thousand years ago.
And for those three and
a half thousand years,
people had no idea what
they were dealing with.
They didn't know what was
this terrible disease.
They didn't know
why they were dying.
They didn't know why
some people survived
and others have died and they
could do nothing about it.
They couldn't name it, let
alone do anything about it.
It will have been one year
from the identification
of Pneumonia in China,
in late December
to the time when
humanity produces
a workable vaccine
for COVID.
Now, am I 100% sure that we
are going to get a vaccine.
No.
Is it very likely?
Yes, it is very likely
by the end of this year,
we are going to have
a vaccine for COVID.
Never before in human history,
have we been able
to produce a vaccine
within that timeframe?
And the reason why we are
able to produce that vaccine
in that timeframe
is many fold.
One, again, it's the richest.
The fact that we have thousands
of doctors and researchers
who are dedicated to
doing nothing else,
but fiddle with these
very exotic viruses,
only a rich society
can employ people
in that kind of profession.
Secondly,
we are rich, but also we
are technologically savvy.
We have access to
supercomputers,
which can match the weaknesses
in the genetic code of COVID
to molecular structure
of different drugs
that are already
in the marketplace.
In other words, the super
computers can tell us
which of the drugs, which are
currently already approved
by FDA and are in use,
which of these drugs
are the best candidate
as a treatment for COVID.
So, that's another reason
why we are ahead of the game.
Communication within 24 hours
after the Chinese decoded,
COVID 19 genetic code, that
information was known to people
across the world.
In the past,
first of all, we didn't
know what genetic code was,
but even then maybe you
would have to publish
your findings in some
sort of a medical journal
and then wait for
weeks and months
until people have read about it.
Now we can do it with an email.
So for all of these reasons,
we are exceptionally fast
in coming up with a solution
to COVID and yes, it is true
that COVID took us by surprise.
Yes, it is true that there
was a lot of suffering,
but we are the best positions,
best positioned humans
in human history
to address this
problem and do it fast.
- That my friend is how you
end a show on a positive note.
I hope people will
check out the book.
I'm telling you,
it's really like,
it's just a perfect
coffee table book.
It really is because
people can flip through it,
and actually learn something.
And it's not too painful.
And I hope to see you in
person one of these days,
once again,
and people should always
check out humanprogress.org.
I try to jump on there
at least once a day,
just to see a couple of stories
that don't make you think the
world is coming to an end,
'cause it probably isn't.
Marian Tupy thanks
for joining this.
- And thank you very
much for those kind words
and good luck to us all.
- Yeah.
Indeed.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversation about
the environment,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our
environment playlist,
and if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.